[Music]
lightly fried my delicious halloumi and
courgette cakes squeeze every last bit
of flavor out of those vegetables
but first i'm preparing a simple slow
roast tomato and watercress salad
these cherry tomatoes are perfect if you
haven't got cherry tomatoes vitamins are
good or even just big
normal plump tomatoes lay the tomatoes
on the tray
and these go into the oven for about 90
minutes
if you turn the oven down really low you
can leave them in overnight
to be honest the longer you leave them
the better they taste
once you've seasoned with salt sprinkle
over with some sugar
and the salt and sugar combine speeds up
the drying process because you want that
nice chewy texture and then you get
these little time flowers and just pick
off the buds garlic sliced
then just spread that on
now the tray looks quite full and
compact but 90 minutes in the oven
you'll see everything shrink down all
the skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies so nicely extra virgin olive
oil that gives a nice earthy flavor to
the tomatoes
place your tomatoes into an oven
preheated to 150 degrees c and cook long
and slow for an hour and a half
now halloumi cakes there's something
quite exciting about halloumi cheese
it's a very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
peel the carrots
[Music]
great not too finely you want that nice
texture
next courgette
the secret is keep it all grated the
same
put that into a sieve
[Music]
a sprinkling of salt will draw out
liquid from the vegetables
then grate the halloumi
halloumi cheese doesn't look that tasty
but once you've got color on it in the
pan it's really
really delicious now
really important to squeeze out the
excess water from the veg
and we'll see all that water that needs
to come out of there
if you didn't do this it'll make your
little patties non-friable because the
whole thing
starts to separate
and then mix in with the cheese
spring onions chop up the whites and the
greens
now we're going to season that with some
delicious fresh mint and fresh coriander
whenever it's vegetarian i like to put a
combination of herbs in there tarragon
parsley mint and coriander basil and
lemongrass
all delicious on their own but in tandem
their flavours play off each other
next
two eggs
in
give that a little mix
add the eggs to the mixture
and then finally a couple of tablespoons
of breadcrumbs the breadcrumbs help dry
out any excess moisture
mix
all the ingredients together
before you start shaping these taste the
mixture
hmm
it's really important to identify the
seasoning now
if you wait until you've cooked them
it'll be too late to adjust the
seasoning
roll them to a large golf ball
shape them like a little mini burger
you could spice these up with some chili
in there if you haven't got fresh chili
chili flakes
and it's something that can be done up a
day in advance
to get your cakes firm and ready for
frying put them into the fridge
uncovered for 25 minutes
pan on
get that nice and hot while i'm waiting
for that i'll get the dressing ready
slice the red chili seeds and all on an
angle into shards
then chop fresh ginger
season with a sprinkle of sugar and salt
add some rice wine vinegar
add a couple of tablespoons of olive oil
to finish off some chopped coriander
[Music]
got that sweet sour spicy flavor
with my chilli dressing done i can start
frying off my halloumi cakes in a hot
oiled pan
we've got a nice crisp edge
you can already start to smell that
sauteed halloumi with the courgettes and
carrots smells delicious really
important for a nice amount of colour on
them
as my cakes sizzle away i can finish off
my roast tomato salad
one of my favorite leaves has to be
watercress just cut off stalks
[Music]
shallot rings
watercress and shallot
go brilliantly well together
the shallot looks so dainty when you
open up these little ringlets
don't forget to turn your cakes
now tomatoes
whatever you don't use just jar them and
put them in the fridge
[Music]
just drop those slow cooked warm
tomatoes over the watercress the
sweetness is incredible absolutely
delicious
a little drizzle of age of smooth
vinegar
gives that tartness to the watercress
watercress is naturally peppery so it
doesn't need any pepper just a little
touch of salt
and then a light sprinkling of extra
virgin olive oil
after five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes are ready
so important to have taken out that
water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate
and then just get your dressing take a
spoon of it
and then tilt it to the side because i
want the garnish i don't want the juice
if that does not
turn you on to become a vegetarian for
the night i honestly don't know what
will
delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
herb cakes with a sumptuous roast tomato
and watercress salad all of the flavor
with none of the meat
when i was growing up my mom was a very
very good cook so we had some great food
but it was always meat and too veg and
the veg definitely played a bit part but
the more attention you pay to cooking
vegetables the more you realize they can
easily take center stage for all the
flavor with known the flesh here's my
ultimate vegetarian dinner
first a hearty starter a bruschetta with
ricotta and succulent griddle courgettes
for my main i'm serving fragrant roasted
beetroot and thyme risotto
[Music]
but i'll be in trouble with the kids if
i don't do a pud
so i'm enlisting the help of my youngest
tilly to rustle up an indulgent
chocolate and lime mousse with crushed
raspberries
[Music]
so if you want to wrap the chocolate
start breaking up in little bits we're
going to make the most amazing white
chocolate mousse our first job is to
bring half of our cream up to the boil
so what kind of cream is that in there
dad that is double cream okay so that's
gonna make a really nice rich
chocolate mousse what's your favorite
sort of chocolate is it white milk dark
um i love white and milk
what's yours i absolutely love
milk chocolate oh that's my guilty
pleasure is it really here we go cream
in
so that goes in there
now
you can see what's happening straight
away can't you it's melting really
quickly melting really quickly so okay
oh excuse me
at least your jumper's white so you
won't spot it yeah i've got a nice
little snack for later
in another bowl add lime zest cold cream
and whisk until it forms soft peaks
the lime cuts the sort of richness of
the cream and that starts to make the
chocolate mousse taste a little bit
lighter
mmm it smells really good the lime gives
it a really nice zingy
zenith you're absolutely right
next add to the melted chocolate mixture
because i'm whisking it's just getting
lighter and lighter and lighter
have a little taste
nice yeah the lime gives it a really
nice taste telly i need the rest for the
mousse
i need them for my tummy no come on
chocolate moves into the fridge
our next job is to separate out three
egg whites
this is why i need you at your absolute
best okay because to whip those whites
it's gonna be really tough so we'll take
it in turns 30 seconds each okay you go
first
seconds gone
come on tilly
15 seconds gone
20 seconds gone come on you can do it 10
seconds to go
five four three
two one and change
exit hold the ball
right no
no way
[Music]
this puny little thing and you come with
a big little machine gun
that's the best way of whipping up egg
whites
start tipping that sugar in slowly
our contentious whipped egg whites will
make our mousse light and airy and when
they've reached soft peaks we can gently
mix in our cool white chocolate and
cream mixture
once the egg whites hit the cream yeah
the chocolate sets
the egg whites keep the cream nice and
fluffy and you get this nice light
mousse in the bowl
now i need you to crush some raspberries
please with some fresh mint
you can see all the juice coming out
now take your mousse
wow that looks really cool now look at
that down the bottom there now
a crushed raspberry delicious
now i'm going to set that in the fridge
if you can use the kind of dough please
our yummy white chocolate mousse will
take at least two hours to set so we can
crack on with our mediterranean-inspired
vegetarian starter
griddle courgette ricotta and mint
bruschetta
for this recipe you'll need a griddle
pan an essential piece of kit for that
char grill look
cut thick slices of chapatta bread
drizzle both sides with olive oil
season with a little salt and pepper
and griddle each side until toasted
then slice a couple of courgettes
diagonally into half a centimetre thick
pieces drizzle and coat in olive oil and
season with salt and pepper
sear on a smoking hot griddle pan in
batches until all the coughettes are bar
marked on both sides
next roughly chop mint leaves and
combine with creamy ricotta cheese
spread your toasty topata with dollops
of minty ricotta and top with your
seared courgette
super simple and super tasty
now we're gonna make a delicious
beetroot risotto we need to get the
shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now have
you ever made a risotto
no i haven't actually shallots please
into the pan for daddy
add a sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic
once you start cooking the risotto it's
really important
to have your stock
gently boiling away
if we're adding cold stock on top of the
rice all the time it just slows down the
process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you cook in a deep pan all the rice
sort of cooks at different temperatures
what stock is that in there dad because
that's a vegetable stock yeah because
you can't have different stocks if it's
more vegetarian can you
have chicken stock i made that mistake
one's putting beef stock in the
vegetarian soup
did you no i didn't matilda are you sure
i'm positive i'm joking
fry off the time how nice does that
smell it smells
delicious rice in that's a bit of a
different rice this is elboria rice it's
a perfect rice for risotto
now it's really important to sear
the rice if we just put the stock in
without sweating off the rice it goes
all starchy so keep on stirring for
daddy
it's just going to make a formula no
flambe on the risotto
to go with our deep red beetroot theme
i'm adding red wine
followed by the first ladle of stock to
get things started now we're off
wow it's giving it a cloudy sort of look
what's happening to the stock the stock
is reducing down and the rice is sucking
it in that's right so the rice is
actually getting nice and plump
one of risotto is live when it's like
this now we can't stop cooking there we
have to kill it all the way okay ready
for the next ladle i'm ready good girl
here we go ladle
in so we have to make this for literally
20 25 minutes
and we're nursing it all the way
beetroots
peel them rub them a little bit of salt
and sugar yeah and a little bit of aged
balsamic barcelona in there roasted them
i'm gonna grate
my parmesan
how's that rice doing the rice is doing
good now that is exactly where we want
to be now look look at that nice glossy
textured rice so beetroot i want you to
put two thirds of the beetroot in there
for me saving one third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
nice looks like it's snowing again and
then we're just gonna get some nice
butter in there the butter gives the
risotto a really nice gloss
look at that beautiful
let that come down let it come down
first
all right get your spoon in there now
for daddy
beautifully there you go good
wonderful
shake it risotto should be like lava
it just
flows out and then the rest of the
beetroot on top
and then
finish
and some extra virgin olive oil
on top
i'll pick up the bruschetta you take
that to the table
okay
let's go danny
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner
delicious courgette ricotta and mint top
bruschetta
an anxious roasted beetroot and thyme
risotto
and for put an indulgent white chocolate
and lime mousse with fresh crushed
raspberries